Al Gore's still very much passionate
about this issue and here to talk more
about the disturbing trend of the
powerful storms were seeing is
meteorologist Jeff Baer Adelie Jeff good
morning good morning
so in Houston last year 56 inches of
rain dumped we're expecting something
like 40 inches of grain dump in the
Carolinas why are these storms hanging
around just just pouring this rain and
water down well that's the big problem
both of these storms have slowed down
now that can happen naturally but there
is evidence from the latest research to
show that it looks like hurricanes may
be slowing down especially in the
coastal plain and because they're
slowing down by as much as 20% or so
they're dropping even more rainfall we
saw that would Harvey we're seeing that
with Florence one of the reasons is the
steering flow seems to be weakening a
little in the atmosphere and we're
getting these big blocking area of high
pressures off of the eastern seaboard we
have one right now and that is got
Florence stuck where it is
Florence is moving very slowly water
temperatures off the eastern seaboard
are boiling hot right now anywhere
between 2 and around 8 or 9 degrees
above normal and what that does is it it
basically enforces the blocking high and
it also invigorates the storm
it makes the storm stronger and the air
temperatures are also warmer it can hold
more water vapor it drops more rain in
the case of Harvey last year we think
potentially it was as much as 15 to 20
percent maybe as much as 35 percent one
report set of extra rainfall due to
climate Jeff is this a long term thing
then this sort of this blocking problem
we have we think that blocks will
increase in the future we think that
steering will probably decrease in the
future so we think this kind of thing is
likely to keep happening in the future
when you think of coastal communities
what about the rising sea levels what's
the impact there it's a big problem
right now we've seen about a little less
than a foot of sea level rise since
around 1900 but that rate is going to
accelerate quickly as we start to melt
the north and south poles over the next
couple of decades I lived in Miami Beach
for a while and I will tell you that
they're doing mitigation right now and
adaptation they're investing 500 million
dollars right now
raise the streets two feet all over
Miami Beach and install pumps that's
just the beginning Miami Beach they are
pioneers in this you're gonna start to
see this mitigation happen up and down
the coastlines of this country and all
around the world and now 40 percent of
the populations on the coastline it's an
incredible want to live there it's
beautiful
well this mean that the intensity of the
storms will also increase we expect that
so the latest research shows that the
intensity of category 4 and category 5
storms is going to increase and is
already increasing right now around the
world but here's the interesting caveat
to that our computer models show that
the number of total hurricanes may
actually go down a little bit in a
warmer climate
so stronger storms for perhaps a few
less of them but really it's the strong
storms that cause the majority of damage
because as you increase the wind the
force and the damage increases
exponentially but we saw even in this
one that the category didn't matter as
much as the rainfall out along with
Harvey as well and that's the big story
with this storm it is crawling and if
you look on the east side and I was on
the lookout for this you'll notice that
the bands are starting to intensify
around Wilmington around New Bern
Morehead City the problem is the storm
is crawling it like three miles an hour
so these bands will be stuck there for
24 to 36 hours we've already had close
to 30 inches of rain and release it's
like Jacksonville North Carolina so are
these sort of slow-moving marathon
storms then these storms that stretch
after a couple of days or more is that a
trend as well we think that is a trend
this storm is likely to be with us
through around Tuesday so the the threat
right now is in the Carolinas watch out
when it hits the Appalachians because
we're gonna see flash flooding off the
mountains and Hills eventually as the
storm heads north into the Appalachians
in Pennsylvania and upstate New York by
the way and New York City on Tuesday
we're gonna see a couple to a few inches
of rain and in the mountainous terrain
we're likely to see runoff and probably
some pretty bad flash flooding quick
question yeah can anyone deny climate
change any longer I don't think it's
possible to do it there are some people
that will do it there are about 8% of
the population that you'll probably
never convert but the truth is it's here
it's now it's serious and we have to
take action if we want to save our
future Jeff berried Ellie thank you
thank you